bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du dip learning le dip learning c'est un
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
qui a littéralement explosé ces
dernières années on avait peut-être déjà
entendu parler si vous avez vu ma vidéo
sur le go ou bien si vous avez vu il ya
quelques mois ces images un peu
psychédélique qui ont été publiés par
google et qui représentait soi-disant un
algorithme de deep learning en train de
rêver alors aujourd'hui on va voir ce
que c'est que le dip learning et
commence à se positionne par rapport aux
autres champs de l'intelligence
artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle on en parle
depuis plus de 50 ans maintenant et
l'histoire du domaine est un peu
tumultueuse ça a commencé par une
période de grand enthousiasme on
s'imaginer qu'on arriverait très vite à
faire des choses assez incroyables
et puis ça a été suivie par une période
un peu plus sombre de désillusions où on
a finalement constaté qu'on avait un peu
sous-estimé les difficultés
je vais pas vous refaire l'histoire du
domaine mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que dans les années 90 après cette
période un peu de désillusions il ya eu
une renaissance de l'intelligence
artificielle sous la forme de ce qu'on
appelle le machine learning ou
l'apprentissage automatique
en bon français le machine learning
c'est un domaine qui étudie comment des
algorithmes peuvent apprendre en
étudiant des exemples et on va voir
exactement ce que ça veut dire et le dip
learning dans tout ça où l'apprentissage
profond ben c'est juste une manière
particulière de faire du machine
learning et je vais vous expliquer en
quoi elle est originale et pourquoi elle
a explosé ces derniers temps pour
comprendre comment des ordinateurs et
des algorithmes peuvent apprendre à
faire des choses on va partir d'un
exemple très simple
imaginons que vous soyez un botaniste et
que vous intéressiez à une certaines
espèces d'arbres bon vous promener en
forêt puis vous fait des observations et
sur chaque arbre que vous croisez vous
relever sa hauteur et le diamètre de son
tronc et puis vous consigner toutes vos
observations dans un tableau de données
alors voilà le tableau 1 chaque ligne
représente un arbre différents dont vous
avez mesuré le diamètre et la hauteur à
une chose simple qu'on peut faire quand
on a des données comme ça c'est de les
représenter graphiquement on met le
diamètre en abscisse la hauteur en
ordonnée et puis chaque point va
représenter un art différent que vous
avez mesuré et voilà ce qu'on obtient
alors vous avec vos yeux et votre
cerveau d'êtres humains vous voyez qu'il
ya un truc notable 1 dans ces données
tous les points sont en gros à peu près
alignés et on a très envie de faire
passer une droite faire passer une
droite comme ça c'est vraiment une bonne
idée parce que ça nous permet de
généraliser
c'est à dire qu'on a un certain nombre
d'observations sur des cas particuliers
qui sont les arbres qu'on a mesurée et
on en tire une relation général qui est
cette droite et grâce à ce lien qu'on a
découvert dans les données on va pouvoir
faire ce qu'on appelle de la prédiction
la prédiction ça veut dire que si je
prends un nouvel arbre de la même espèce
qu'on n'a pas encore mesuré et que je
vous donne son diamètre et bien vous
pouvez grâce à cette droite estime et sa
hauteur alors le terme de prédiction il
est peut-être un peu mal choisie parce
qu'il s'agit pas de prédire l'avenir à
il s'agit plutôt de deviner une valeur
qu'on ne possède pas
je résume la démarche comprend des
données qui sont des observations
particulières on découvre un lien dans
ces données
et ce lien nous permet de généraliser de
faire des prédictions et bien ici on a
tous les ingrédients de ce que c'est que
le machine learning le machine learning
c'est essayer de faire la même chose
avec des algorithmes en supposant qu'on
prenne ces mêmes données et qu'on les
donne un ordinateur
on peut très bien imaginer un algorithme
qui va chercher comme nous à faire
passer une droite parmi les points une
droite s'est défini par deux choses une
pente petit à une ordonné à l'origine
qu'on m'appelait petit b vous savez
cette classique y égal à x + b eh bien
on peut imaginer un algorithme qui fasse
varié a et b jusqu'à trouver une droite
qui colle bien aux nuages des points
souvent l'image comprend sept s'imaginer
que a et b les paramètres de la droite
c'est un peu comme deux boutons que
l'algorithme peut faire tourner jusqu'à
trouver la meilleure droite possible
et une fois qu'on a fait ça on touche
plus à nos deux boutons et on a une
droite qui permet à l'algorithme de
généraliser d'extrapoler à des cas qui
l'a jamais vu il suffit d'utiliser
l'équation de la droite
et voilà le machine learning en gros
c'est ça on a des données ici sous la
forme d'une entrée x et d'une sortie y
on les présentait un algorithme qui a
des boutons et qu'il est tourner jusqu'à
ce qu'ils aient compris le lien entre x
et y
ça c'est tout ce qu'on appelle la phase
d'apprentissage et puis une fois que
c'est fait on peut faire des prédictions
et ça c'est le but ultime d'un
algorithme machine learning est capable
de faire des prédictions des
extrapolations
alors évidemment ici j'ai pris un
exemple super basique en entrée on n'a
qu'un seul nombre x qui est le diamètre
de l'arbre ont sorti un seul nombre y
qui est sa taille et en plus le lien
entre les deux il est très simple
puisque c'est une simple droite mais
dans les vrais problèmes de machine
learning on peut avoir des relations qui
sont beaucoup plus compliquées et puis
surtout on peut avoir beaucoup plus
qu'une seule donnée en entrée pour le
voir on va prendre quelques exemples
d'application d'une machine learning
vous avez certainement déjà remarqué que
votre fils facebook il vous montre pas
toutes les nouvelles de vos amis ou des
pages auxquelles vous êtes abonné il en
choisit seulement certaines et il
voulait présente dans un certaine nombre
est bien derrière il ya un algorithme
machine learning qui essaye de
comprendre quelles sont les nouvelles
qui ont le plus de chance de vous
intéresser
cet algorithme y prend en entrée tout un
tas de caractéristiques de la nouvelle
qu'il a postées camp de quoi elle parle
sa nature etc et ils essayent de prédire
si ça va vous intéresser ou pas un autre
exemple d'utilisation d'une machine
learning c'est la détection de fraude
sur internet
chaque fois que vous utilisez votre
carte de crédit sur internet eh bien il
ya un algorithme quelque part qui tourne
pour essayer d'estimer si c'est bien
vous ou si c'est une fraude et pour ça
il utilise des données d'entrée qui sont
la nature de la transaction sa
localisation sont longtemps et puis tout
un tableau de données du même genre
encore un autre exemple d'utilisation du
machine learning dont on va
particulièrement parler aujourd'hui
c'est la reconnaissance d'image la
reconnaissance d'image ça consiste à
essayer de faire un algorithme qui prend
en données d'entrée une image et dont le
but est d'essayer de deviner en sortie
ce que représente l'image vous voyez
sur ces quelques exemples que ma droite
à x + b avec ses deux boutons en fait
elle va être largement insuffisante
il nous faut quelque chose qui soit
capable de prendre plein de données
d'entrée et surtout de capturer des
relations bien plus complexe que ça
entre les entrées et les sorties
eh ben c'est là qu'interviennent les
réseaux de neurones
un neurone c'est quelque chose qui va
jouer le même rôle que ma droite tout à
l'heure c'est à dire c'est une fonction
mathématique qui va mettre en relation
des entrées x avec une sortie y
alors évidemment c'est important de
préciser que ce dont on parle là c'est
un neurones artificiels c'est à dire
c'est une construction mathématiques qui
imite grossièrement le fonctionnement
d'un vrai neurones
les vrais neurones biologique ce sont
des cellules qu'on trouve dans notre
système nerveux et qui sont connectées
les unes aux autres
chaque neurone possède une terminaison
qu'on appelle un axones et par laquelle
le neurone peut envoyer un signal à
d'autres neurones la manière dont
fonctionne un neurone c'est la suivante
le neurone reçoit ou pas un signal
électrique d autres neurones qui sont
connectés à lui et en fonction de ces
signaux il fait un truc assez binaire
soit ils en voient rien dans son axe
zone soit il envoie un signal électrique
et dans ce cas là on dit qu'il décharge
l'idée du neurone artificielle qui date
déjà d'il ya plusieurs décennies
ces demies mais ce comportement par une
fonction mathématique alors voilà le
principe
imaginons qu'on ait un neurones
artificiels avec mettons trois entrées
on va les appeler x1 x2 x3 on fait la
somme de ses trois entrées en affectant
un coefficient à chacune
on appelle ça un poids si la somme
obtenue est supérieur à un certain seuil
le neurone va envoyer un an sortie et
sinon il va envoyer 0 à neurones
artificiels voyez donc que c'est une
fonction mathématique qui prend des ziks
en entrée et qui sort un y en sortie et
cette fonction elle a des boutons qu'on
peut tourner qui sont les poids et le
seuil un peu de la même manière qu'on
pouvait changer les coefficients a et b
sur la droite alors le problème c'est
que un neurone tout seul en fait ça
suffit pas pour faire des relations très
compliquées mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les neurones
on peut en associés plein ensemble et
les empiler pour faire des fonctions
beaucoup plus compliqué et c'est ça
qu'on appelle des réseaux de neurones
alors on devrait plutôt dire des réseaux
de neurones artificiels en empilant des
neurones comme ça on peut fabriquer des
fonctions aussi compliqué qu'on veut
avec plein d'entrées et plein de sortie
et surtout plein de boutons à tourner
autant que de poids et de seuil dans le
réseau ces réseaux de neurones
l'avantagent c'est qu'ils sont très
polyvalents
on peut les adapter à plein de type
d'entrée ou de sortie mais dans le fond
on les utilise de la même manière que ma
droite tout à l'heure on prend un réseau
de neurones
on lui présente une base de données
d'exemple d'entrée sortie et on tourne
tous ses boutons jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse
correctement le lien entre les entrées
et les sorties
je vous rappelle qu'on appelle ça la
phase d'apprentissage
et une fois qu'on a fait ça notre réseau
est entraîné et il est capable de
prédire la sortie si on lui présente une
nouvelle entrée et ça c'est la phase de
prédiction un des inconvénients des
réseaux de neurones par rapport à ma
droite de tout à l'heure c'est que c'est
ce qu'on appelle parfois un modèle
boîtes noires c'est à dire qu'une fois
qu'on a trouvé toutes les bonne position
des boutons on se retrouve avec une
fonction qui mathématiquement est un peu
compliqué et c'est un peu difficile de
l'interpréter mais bon en général tant
que le réseau de neurones donne la bonne
réponse
on est content et d'ailleurs il
semblerait que l'apprentissage dans le
cas des réseaux de neurones artificiels
ressemble pas mal à ce qui se passe en
réalité dans notre cerveau quand on
apprend des choses la force des
connexions entre neurones se modifie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité
synaptique
et ça se fait d'une manière qu'on peut
comparer à la façon dont on joue sur les
poids dans notre réseau de neurones
artificiels
alors encore une fois le but des réseaux
de neurones c'est pas de faire un modèle
de notre cerveau hein c'est juste une
construction mathématiques qui s'en
inspirent bon tout ça c'était pour la
théorie
maintenant on va passer à la pratique
on la dit quand on veut faire un réseau
de neurones on empile plein de fois
cette unité élémentaire qu'on appelle le
neurones artificiels
maintenant il ya une question c'est
combien il faut en mettre dans notre
réseau si on s'inspire de notre cerveau
dans notre cerveau il ya à peu près 100
milliards de neurones et comme il peut y
avoir plusieurs milliers de synapses
pour chaque neurone ça nous met pas loin
du million milliards de connexions alors
très clairement on va pas du tout
pouvoir faire ça avec un réseaux
neuronaux et même sans aller jusque là
en fait dès qu'on met trop de neurones
dans notre réseau ça fait beaucoup trop
de boutons qu'on peut tourner et ça
devient très difficile de trouver les
bonnes positions des boutons c'est à
dire que la phase d'apprentissage
devient quasiment impossible
c'est pour ça qu'à c'est souvent en
pratique on se limite à une structure
très simple avec seulement trois couches
de neurones les neurones d'entrée qui
sont les x le ou les neurones de sortie
c'est le y et puis une couche
intermédiaire de neurones et plus on met
deux neurones dans la couche
intermédiaire plus le réseau est a
priori polyvalent et puissant mais plus
il devient compliqué a entraîné à
trouver les bonnes positions des boutons
et si on essaye d'ajouter des couches de
plus on se noie assez vite dans la
complexité de la phase d'apprentissage
pour des problèmes avec un nombre
raisonnable de données d'entrée comme
par exemple de la détection de fraude
sur internet
ce genre de méthode peut très bien
marché mais pour faire de la
reconnaissance d'image
en fait c'est vite limité et si on prend
une photo de petite taille mais ton 400
par 400 ça fait tout de suite 160000
pixels c'est à dire 160 minutes nombre a
filé en entrée au réseau et on se
retrouve obligé d'utiliser un réseau
extrêmement compliqué qu'on n'arrivera
pas à entraîner et donc en somme
balancer une image brute dans un réseau
de neurones et ben ça marche pas alors
heureusement il existe une méthode pour
s'en sortir c'est celle de fabriquer des
caractéristiques intermédiaire de
l'image imaginons qu'on s'intéresse à un
problème qui consiste à reconnaître des
véhicules voulait fabriquer un
algorithme à qui on donne une image et
qui nous disent si cette image
représente d'une voiture un bus un train
une moto etc
nous en tant qu'être humain il existe un
certain nombre de caractéristiques qui
nous permettent de faire la différence
on peut par exemple compter le nombre de
roues à part entre
regardez le rapport largeur hauteur
regardez quelle est la couleur dominante
la quantité de surfaces vitrées le
nombre de vitres leur forme et c'est la
solution pour faire de la reconnaissance
d'image d'un genre de situation c'est de
créer un algorithme intermédiaires qui
sera pas un réseau de neurones et dont
le but va être d'analyser les images et
d'extraire toutes ces caractéristiques
intéressantes et se sont ensuite ses
caractéristiques qu'on va donner à un
réseau de neurones pour faire la
reconnaissance
cette approche elle peut fonctionner
parce que la quantité de données
d'entrée qu'on va filer au réseau elle
va être bien inférieur à ce qu'on aurait
si on avait filé l'image brute en entier
les caractéristiques qui résume l'image
il va y avoir quelques dizaines maximum
quelques centaines
et comme on a résumé l'image en la
réduisant à une liste de
caractéristiques essentielles
on dit parfois qu'on a fait une
abstraction de l'image tout ça c'est
très bien mais ça pose quand même un
petit problème c'est que la qualité de
la reconnaissance va fortement dépendre
de la manière dont on a fait ce travail
intermédiaires de construction des
caractéristiques essentielles de l'image
et pour faire correctement ce travail il
faut savoir de quoi on parle dans mon
exemple des véhicules il faut savoir que
ce qui est important pour différencier
un véhicule d'un autre c'est le nombre
de roues les vitres etc et donc il faut
entre guillemets un expert du domaine et
c'est donc le concepteur de l'algorithme
intermédiaires qui fait en quelque sorte
une bonne partie du travail
d'intelligence et bien c'est pour
pallier à sa qu'intervient le dit
pleurer
on a vu comment fonctionnait le machine
learning classique et on a vu comment on
pouvait l'utiliser pour faire de la
reconnaissance d'image pourvu qu'on ait
une étape précédente qui soit une étape
de construction des caractéristiques
essentielles de l'image qu'on pourrait
ensuite donnée à un réseau de neurones
l'idée un peu folle du dic learning
c'est de sauter cette étape
en gros on va faire un gros réseau avec
plein plein de couches de neurones et à
qui on file l'image brute
c'est ce qu'on appelle un réseau profond
d'où l'appellation d'apprentissage
profond ou deep learning en anglais
alors je vous ai dit a priori cette idée
elle peut pas fonctionner ça fait
beaucoup trop de neurones ça fait
beaucoup trop de boutons à tourner et la
phase d'apprentissage ne marche pas eh
bien il ya quand même des gens qui ont
voulu essayer un de ces pionniers c'est
un français qui s'appelle yann lequin et
qui a commencé à utiliser ces méthodes
dans les années 90 à l'époque la
communauté de l'intelligence
artificielle n'était pas du tout
convaincu et préféré s'intéresser à
d'autres trucs et pendant à peu près
deux décennies n'y a qu'une poignée de
personnes dans le monde qui ont continué
à essayer de faire du diplôme ning sauf
qu'en 2012 il ya eu une explosion
il faut savoir que tous les ans il ya
une compétition de reconnaissance
d'image qui est organisée où tous les
meilleurs algorithmes du monde
s'affrontent
vous pouvez voir ici les pourcentage
d'erreurs obtenus par les différents
algorithmes de la compétition en 2010 et
en 2011 et plus ce pourcentage est
faible meilleur et l'algorithme est bien
en 2012
à la surprise générale c'est un
algorithme de deep learning qui a
largement battu tout le monde et dès
l'année suivante
tout le monde s'est mis à faire du dip
learning dans cette compétition
évidemment ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi
soudainement un algorithme de deep
learning marche mieux que les méthodes
habituelles alors que pendant 20 ans
tout le monde avait pensé que ça
marchera jamais alors là dit dans les
méthodes habituelles on a un algorithme
qui extrait de l'image les
caractéristiques essentielles qui résume
l'image qui en donne une abstraction et
ses caractéristiques normalement les
fils à un réseau qui est peu profond le
petit miracle qui se produit avec le
deep learning c'est que si on a réussi à
entraîner le réseau correctement on se
rend compte que les couches supérieures
contiennent ses caractéristiques
essentielles
tous les éléments importants l'image qui
peuvent servir à la reconnaître c'est à
dire que l'algorithme les à fabriquer
lui-même il les a découverts sans qu'on
ait eu besoin de faire le travail pour
lui si on prend l'exemple de la
reconnaissance de véhicules ça veut dire
qu'on n'aurait pas besoin de dire à
l'algorithme ce que c'est qu'une roue et
le fait que une rousse est important
pour reconnaître un véhicule non
l'algorithme en fait découvrir est tout
seul le concept de roue et l'importance
de la roue pour classifier les véhicules
je voulais dit suite au succès respecte
q l'air d'un algorithme de deep learning
dans la compétition de reconnaissance
d'image de 2012 tout le monde s'est mis
à faire du diplôme ling et il ya le look
un qui était resté entre temps un petit
peu dans l'ombre est soudainement
devenue l'une des superstars de
l'intelligence artificielle
évidemment tout le monde s'est mis a
embauché des spécialistes de deep
learning google amazon baidu etc et puis
bien sûr facebook qui a embauché
quelqu'un comme directeur de son
laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle
il ya quand même quelque chose que j'ai
pas encore dit c'est pourquoi cette
méthode à laquelle personne ne croyait
il ya encore quelques années s'est mise
à marcher soudainement et bien comme
souvent il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord
les algorithmes ont progressé comme
toujours notamment contrairement à ce
que je peux laisser penser on n'utilise
pas n'importe quel réseau profonde c'est
pas juste un tas de neurones empilés et
on a d architecture particulière qui
fonctionne bien et aussi bien sûr une
raison matérielle c'est la puissance de
calcul et notamment les progrès des
processeurs de cartes graphiques un les
gpu qui sont plus puissants que les
processeurs traditionnelle quand il
s'agit de faire des choses liées à
l'image
mais la vraie raison du succès des
algorithmes de deep learning notamment
en reconnaissance d'image ça a été la
disponibilité des données je vous ai dit
quand on fait un réseau profond on peut
se retrouver avec des milliers voire des
millions de neurones et donc ça peut
faire des millions de boutons qu'il faut
tourner pendant la phase d'apprentissage
jusqu'à trouver la bonne relation et
bien pour faire ça il faut des millions
d' exemple à montrer au réseau en 2009
il ya un laboratoire de standford qui a
rendu publique une base de données qui
s'appelle images nettes et qui contient
aujourd'hui plus de 15 millions d'image
classifiés sévère qu'on a des images et
en face de chaque image
on a une description de ce que c'est
c'est à dire une voiture un chien une
vague etc
il ya plus de 10000 catégories
différentes alors vous pouvez faire le
test et vous pouvez chercher dans
l'image net par exemple les images qui
représentent un chat et je crois qu'un à
plusieurs dizaines de milliers et donc
quand on balance toutes ces images un
malgré deux diplômes ning on n'a pas
besoin de lui dire quelles sont les
caractéristiques essentielles qui font
qu'un chat est un chat
la forme de la planète la couleur des
yeux la taille des oreilles etc
l'algorithme va les découvrir tout seul
à l'heure actuelle on peut faire des
réseaux profond qui ont plus d'une
centaine de coups et plusieurs millions
de neurones
alors on est encore très loin du cerveau
mais les performances en reconnaissance
d'image sont quand même assez
spectaculaire vous pouvez voir quelques
exemples ici et quand on sait que chaque
jour sur facebook c'est près de 800
millions d'image qui sont claude et on
comprend bien leur intérêt pour avoir un
algorithme qui soit capable de
reconnaître rapidement ce qu'il ya dans
une photo c'est vrai que des fois ça
rate
heureusement il ya d'autres applications
du dip learning que celle d'analyser les
détails graphiques de notre vie privée
qu'on partage sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple il existe des algorithmes
qui sont capables d'analyser des scènes
sur une image et de les décrire
automatiquement par une phrase ça peut
être plutôt utile pour les malvoyants
une autre application c'est la conduite
autonome vous savez la voiture qui se
conduit toute seule et dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment pour prendre un
exemple qui est donnée par félix qui est
une des pionnières de images nettes
c'est quand même vachement important
pour une voiture autonome d'être capable
de reconnaître un sac en papier qui est
froissé sur la route et sur lequel elle
pourra couler d'un rocher qui est posé
au milieu de la route et qui vaudrait
peut-être mieux éviter
mais les applications que je trouve les
plus intéressantes du dip le remix et la
capacité à fabriquer des images je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure un algorithme de
deep leurs digues un réseau profond si
vous lui donnez une image brute en
entrée il va découvrir tout seul comment
résumer cette image brute par une série
de caractéristiques essentielles et là
je me simplifie beaucoup mais en gros on
peut essayer de prendre le réseau dans
l'autre sens et de faire en sorte que si
on lui donne en entrée une série de
nombres y produisent une image en sortie
et cette image elle sera nouvelle sera
unique et elle aura les caractéristiques
correspondante à ce qu'on à entrer mais
ce sera une image inventé de toutes
pièces
les algorithmes et qui sont capables de
faire ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des
modèles génératif par exemple si vous
voyez un exemple récent qui est assez
spectaculaire
on a utilisé un modèle génératif créé
par un algorithme de deep learning pour
créer des chambres à coucher vous avez
toute une série de chambres à coucher
qui ont été inventés par un algorithme
et ça marche aussi avec des chaises ou
alors avec des personnages de manga bon
puis mon exemple préféré c'est celui-ci
il s'agit de pochettes d'albums qui ont
été complètement inventée par un
algorithme de diplômes ning qui
auparavant avait étudié des vrais
pochette d'album
l'exemple le plus médiatique même si
c'est pas forcément le plus utile c'est
celui dont j'ai parlé au début c'est
google dit jane il s'agit d'un réseau
qu'on a entraîné sur tout un tas d'image
et qu'ensuite on a utilisé pour produire
des images un peu psychédélique
le principe c'est un peu le même que
quand on s'amuse à essayer de trouver
des formes dans les nuages vous savez
quand on joue à regarder les nuages
en gros on peut essayer de se forcer à y
voir d'autres trucs que des nuages
ici on a donné des images à un réseau
profond et on l'a forcé à essayer d'y
voir autre chose et voilà le résultat
c'est sympa non encore une fois il
s'agit d'un exemple un peu anecdotique
j'espère quand même vous avoir
convaincus qu'il ya plein d'applications
fantastique pour le diplôme ning et je
suis sûr que d'ici quelques années on
trouvera ce genre d'algorithmes partout
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si vous
voulez aller plus loin je vous en
conseille deux autres la première c'est
celle de faye felli qui est donc une des
créatrices de images nettes qui à la
conférence ted a présenté le problème de
la reconnaissance d'imagés ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui c'est assez rapide
si vous voulez aller quand même beaucoup
plus loin vous pouvez aller voir la
leçon inaugurale de yann le quéau
collège de france ça dure plus longtemps
il va beaucoup plus dans les détails
comme d'habitude vous pouvez me
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook twitter vous pouvez me soutenir
sur tipi merci à tous les types qui me
soutiennent vous pouvez aussi aller
jeter un oeil à bouquin que j'ai sorti
chez flammarion
et pour ceux qui sont intéressés à me
rencontrer en vrai je serai le 16 avril
à vulgarisateur à lyon donc n'hésitez
pas à aller voir et n'hésitez pas à
venir assister à des conférences
merci et à bientôt